el sueño de lula de volver a la cima de
la política brasileña está un poco más
cerca de hacerse realidad la corte
suprema- concluyó que el juez sergio
moro a cargo de las investigaciones que
llevaron a la caída de lula no fueron
imparciales el segundo panel reconoce la
parcialidad del ex juez sergio moro en
la condena de lula en el caso triplex
por decisión mayoritaria el colegiado
entendió que moro actuó con motivación
política en la conducción del proceso
del expresidente lula en el juzgado
número 13 federal de curitiba otro
impulso para lula el histórico político
está de vuelta en brasil la noticia
llega sólo dos semanas después de que la
corte suprema- absolver a lula por sus
cargos de corrupción allanando su camino
a la presidencia
yo fui víctima de la mayor mentira legal
en 500 años de historia jurídica
contada lula estuvo al frente de brasil
durante su boom económico desde el 2003
hasta el final de la década pero su
reputación fue manchada tras ser
sentenciado a 26 años de prisión por
recibir sobornos
sergio moro fue el juez que decidió la
sentencia encabezó la investigación y
abarató el caso implicó a varios
políticos y empresarios que estaban en
la cima del país acusados de la
malversación de millones de dólares en
petrobras la compañía petrolera estatal
los seguidores de lula aseguran que moro
conspiró para evitar que el líder de
izquierdas ocupara la presidencia en
2018 ya que era el candidato favorito
tras los comicios moros se convirtió en
el ministro de justicia del gobierno de
bolsonaro una evidencia según los jueces
que dieron la razón a lula de que moro
no fue imparcial